hey guys it's JWoww what's up guys mic
situation hey JWoww it's Nikki hey
Nicole and Deena and we are about to
play a Jersey Shore trivia game and
we're gonna get everything right we'd
better be embarrassing now we're gonna
get it wrong my question is in the show
that it pilote episode
oh yes first to arrive at the house Mike
Pauly D Vinny J whoo it was Mike right
wasn't it it was like I remember all
three of them were Mike came in first
we got that right Paulie came in after
me yeah did you like talk to yourself no
I really checked out the situation in
the house and everybody's okay yeah no
pun intended but yourself
you literally try pretty but pretty much
back then I was question god it's
looking JWoww dresser note to Sam oh
dear Sam - Sammi - ooh Sam they're
marked here was it Sam oh dear Sam
dear Sam are you sure you sure it wasn't
just fine yeah I got it right dear - Sam
no it was Sam when did she go yeah you
addressed her - Sam no dear Sam oh
that's why she got mad yeah the first
night in fed the infamous note Angelina
famously arrived at the shore house with
a trash bag as her suitcase what color
was that famous bag black white dark
green or gray to be honest I might be
black I think she arrived with a white
trash bag like the scented ones it smell
like I would say black trash bags are
stronger and at that particular time I
think she went with what I think it was
black it was oh my god I was wrong what
did Mike eat while walking Pauly D hook
up with a girl an egg sandwich a hot
pocket a slice of pizza a bowl of cereal
do you is an egg sandwich there was a
family that was definitely a sandwich
big sandwich maker oh I hit hoppy pocket
bummer you got it I knew it wasn't
Ronnie and Sammi got into a big fight
after he compared her big toe to
SpongeBob SquarePants Fred Flintstone
Homer Simpson or scooby-doo you're
traumatizing me the gang went to lots of
clubs besides karma which of these is
not the name of a club they visited
bamboo bed as tax Eden and I was very
relaxing that's got it smell like the
garden I'm in a field drinking champagne
yes sounds a bit rowdy like God where
did Deena say people should go to school
oh I know this one you fell out of barn
out of beach at a casino at a gym I'd
say had a bar yes I would have done so
much better in school I would piss all
in the grades like oh I've relaxed I
mean not preschool or elementary school
what was the name of the gangs pizzeria
boss in Italy just sent me Angelo
Marco Mario I remember do you guys
remember yes that's actually the hardest
one for me to remember I gave zero I go
out I go in there when Snooki and JWoww
found our Magnum condom in the smush
room who did they suspect it belong to
none Pauly D Vinny
Mike or Ronny remember oh this is Miami
my family says healthy well dreamy then
he always said he had like the big
condoms yeah secretly he has
secretly put the shmita moe well let's
go with Vinny cause that's what he
always said yeah got it
what snack did JWoww leave the club
early to go home and eat turkey and
ginger ale
so cost me an orange juice Bologna and
kool-aid or ham and what was that cause
of the infinite like oily fog in season
three I'm gonna redo that because
someone skipped over me of the infamous
toilet clog in season three a tank top a
shoe a can of spray or poop I remember
this because it was very light this
girl's kept getting blamed for the
toilet knob and it was anyway Oh
white boy yeah Vinny and I know what
happened I'm not doing this so we try to
flush it down the toilet hey guys the
italian flag was paint on the garage of
the shore house which of these is the
correct Italian flag I think I got it
right it is it's not left or right it's
the right
[Music]
Jersey Shore expert yeah I got 11 out of
12 I don't know which one I got but I'm
still an expert same cuz I was there
well and you know what I was actually
not there for the no you freakin Road no
[Applause]
you were telling me what to write and I
was like we can't do like dear Sam or
something like that because you can't
think okay well I pick dear Santa if you
want to beat our score and click the
link in the description description box
up there if you want to beat our score
and click the link if you want to quit
if you think you can beat our score
click the link in the description box
[Music]